I cannot and will not throw away all the
gains we have made together and so the
changes we are making are limited and
cautious it's thanks to the cautionary
shown so far that all five tests are
being met and that's not my achievement
or the government's achievement it is
your achieve and it's only possible
thanks to your resolve and dedication to
our national purpose to overcome this
virus so the result is we can move
forward with adjusting the lockdown in
England on Monday first as I set out on
Sunday we will now reopen schools two
more children closing schools has
deprived children of their education and
as so often it is the most disadvantaged
pupils who risk being hardest hit on
Monday we will start to put this right
in a safe way by reopening nurseries and
other earlier settings and reception
year 1 and year 6 in primary schools a
fortnight later on the 15th of June
secondary schools will begin to provide
some face-to-face contact time fears ten
and twelve second we will also start to
reopen shops as we restart our economy
and will begin on Monday with outdoor
retail and car showrooms where social
distancing is generally easier and a
fortnight later on the 15th of June we
intend to reopen other non-essential
retail but only provided the five tests
are still being met and shops have been
made coded secure lastly I know the toll
the lockdown has taken on families and
friends who have been unable to see each
other
so from Monday we will allow up to six
people to meet outside provided the
from different households continues
strictly to observe social distancing
rules by staying two meters apart at the
moment as you know people can meet in
parks but not in private Gardens and
this was a cautious first step but we
know that there is no difference in the
health risk so we will now allow people
to meet in gardens and other private
outdoor spaces these changes mean that
friends and family can start to meet
their loved ones perhaps seeing both
parents at once or both grandparents at
once and I know that for many people
this will be a long-awaited and joyful
moment but I must stress that to control
the virus everyone needs to stay alert
at responsibly strictly observe social
distancing rules and stay two metres
apart from those you do not live with
minimizing contact with others is still
the best way to prevent transmission you
should also try to avoid seeing people
from too many households in quick
succession so that we can avoid the risk
of quick transmission from lots of
different families and continue to
control the virus and it remains the
case that people should not be inside
the homes of their friends and families
not inside the homes of your friends and
families unless it is to access the
garden to get to the garden I should add
that at this stage I am afraid that
those who have been asked to to to
shield themselves should continue to do
so and I want to say to those extremely
clinically vulnerable people who are now
being shielded that I do understand how
difficult this has been for you
especially and I want to thank you for
all the efforts you have gone to because
your action
have helped the NHS to cope well looking
Catholic how we can make your life
easier and how we can better support you
and we want to say more on that soon I
want to reassure everyone that we can
make all of the changes I have outlined
in a safe way we know that children and
particularly young children are much
less likely to be seriously affected by
the virus we know that if shops enforce
social distancing as required by our
kovat secure guidelines then the virus
is less likely to spread and crucially
we know that transmission of the virus
is far lower outdoors so we can
confidently allow more interaction
outside I understand that people will
have questions as how to do as to how to
do all of this safely and we will
publish guidance on these changes to
help people to help you make the most of
them now I know inevitably that there
may be some anomalies or apparent
inconsistencies in these rules and
clearly what we're proposing is still
just a fraction of the social
interaction each of us would normally
enjoy I know many of you will find this
frustrating and I'm sorry about that but
I'm afraid that is unavoidable giving
them given the nature of the invisible
enemy that we are fighting it's a
complex problem and we're asking for
everyone's patience as we work through
it
together we will inevitably not yet
everything right first time but I must
ask everyone to remember that it's the
same patience the same hard work and
sacrifices of the British people in
lockdown that have got us so far and
allowed us to make the progress and the
progress that we have by protecting the
NHS getting us through the peak and
getting this virus under control
we are able to deliver all of the
adjustments and easing of restrictions I
have set out today these adjustments are
most of those we set out to achieve in
step 2 of our roadmap of our roadmap and
we have also been able to have them in
place by June the first as we had hoped
and there's no doubt that we're making
progress and I'm hopeful that in the
coming weeks we may be able to do more
because obviously while protecting the
health and safety of the public is and
must always be our number one priority
we must also work to restart our economy
and society so as many people as
possible can begin returning to their
way of life but I want to reaffirm that
fundamental commitment to the British
people that all the steps we have taken
and will take are conditional they are
conditional on all the data and all the
scientific advice and it is that
scientific advice which will help us to
judge what we are doing is safe and I
have to warn you in all frankness as we
go forwards that there will be further
local outbreaks so we will monitor what
is going on very carefully we will put
on the brakes as required and where
necessary we will re impose measures and
it's very important to be clear about
that upfront